الى تونس حيث قال الامين العام للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي ان
اتحاد الشغل اصبح مستهدفا من اجل تمرير
الاصلاحات التي اقترحها رئيس الجمهوريه
وخلال الاجتماع الطارئ الذي عقده اتحاد
الشغل اضافه
ان يبعد الانظار عن الفشل الذريع لخياراته
الاقتصاديه وفق تعبيره
اتحاد روم الساده وقلناه من قبل
وانكشف المستور بكل الالاعيب معناها اللي
موجوده
وعلاش الاتحاد مستهدف في تلك الفتره
يريدون تمرير الاصلاحات الموجهه التي
يتحدثوا عليها دائما وابدا
في الاصلاحات الموجعه يلزم اله الراي
العام بيطر هات فارغه
ويجر معناها يقول لهم اني ها هو السبب
البلاء هو الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
الشعب التونسي يعرف
انه عنده منظمه اللي هي مكسب من المكاسب
الوطنيه
من مقر اجتماع الهيئه الاداريه للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل بتونس مدرسه الجزيره
سيف الدين بوعلك سيف الدين كيف نفهم قول
الطبوبي بان الاتحاد اصبح مستهدفا
الاتحاد جلال مستهدف لعده اعتبارات كما
ترى المنظمه النقابيه اولا الاتحاد كان قد
اطلق مبادره للحوار الوطني قد تختلف بشكل
كبير عن المسار السياسي والاقتصادي
والمالي الذي تتخذها السلطات التونسيه
خاصه نتحدث طبعا على راس السلطه التنفيذيه
الرئيس قيس سعيد هذه مساله قد تكون نقطه
خلاف كبيره بين الاتحاد العام التونسي
الشغل والرئيس قيس سعيد الذي تحاشى على
امتداد الاشهر الفارطه منذ حديث الاتحاد
عن اطلاق مبادره وطنيه رفقه عدد من
المنظمات عن الحديث عنها ولكن يقول الحد
الاتحاد العام انه يرفض ان يتم تحجيم
تواجده في الساحه على المساله النقابيه
العماليه البحته وانما له تصورات ورؤى في
الساحه الوطنيه حول حول المسائل السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه هذه مساله
المساله الثانيه ان الاتحاد العام
التونسيو خلال الفتره الفارطه انتقد
المسار السياسي خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات التشريعيه التي شهدت اضعف
نسبه مشاركه في هذه في هذا المسار
الانتخابي الذي ايضا اقره الرئيس قيس سعيد
النقطه المهمه الاخرى وشديده الاهميه في
الحقيقه الجلال تتعلق
بموقف الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل من
الاصلاحات التي قد تذهب فيها السلطات
التونسيه والحكومه التونسيه خاصه في علاقه
بالاتفاق واتفاق القرض مع صندوق النقد
الدولي طبعا الاتحاد يضع نقاط وخطوط حمراء
في هذه المساله تحديدا ويرفض رفع الدعم عن
المواد الاساسيه وهذا مطروح في
المناقشات مع صندوق النقد الدولي هو يرفض
ايضا تجميد الاجور وهذا مطروح ايضا في
مناقشات صندوق النقد الدولي وايضا ي
التجميد اقل اجور والانتدابات والتفويت في
المؤسسات مؤسسات القطاع العام ويريد ان
يتم اصلاحها حاله بحاله وليس التفريط فيها
وهذا ايضا مطروح في مناقشات صندوق النقد
الدولي وبالتالي هناك اعتقاد لدى السلطات
بان الاتحاد يقف حجر عثره في هذا الاتفاق
الذي يمثل نقطه مهمه ومفصيليه
والنقطه التي او القطره التي افاضت الكاس
جلال تتعلق بايقاف احد القيادات النقابيه
بعد اعلان اضراب نقابه الطرقات السياره
وهو اضراب معلن ومبرمج ويقول النقابه
نقابه الاتحاد العربي انه
تم برمجته وهو قانوني لا يوجد اي اشكال
وبالتالي السلطات التونسيه تستهدف راسا
العمليه النقابيه طبعا جاء هذا عمليه
ايقاف احد المسؤولين بعد خطاب رئيس سعيد
فيه تكنه للحرس الوطني وهو ما اعتبره
الاتحاد او الطبوبي ادخالا
للمؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه في قلب العمليه
السياسيه
ان الرئيس مدعوم من هذه المؤسسه جلال نعم
شكرا لك يا نور الدين في تونس